voici à la suite de la décision
présidentielle l'espace gagné par le
jardin des halles ici 9000 m² à la place
du centre du commerce international qui
rase l'installer ailleurs de l'autre
côté 7000 m² à la place des logements
des magasins et du centre d'antiquaires
prévu par la sema la société
l'aménagement des halles du projet de la
sema qui était en cours de réalisation
il ne resterait que le forum commercial
l'hôtel de 300 chambres et bien sûr la
grande gare souterraine du métro express
régional
mais il y a un problème à résoudre que
faire de cet énorme trou creusé à
l'intention du centre international le
ministère de l'équipement doit présenter
son rapport au président la république
avant la fin du mois de septembre
pour l'instant on en est aux hypothèses
on parle d'un central téléphonique d'un
palais des sports d'un centre
audiovisuel
ce ne sont encore que des bruits on se
doute que l'aspect même du nouveau
jardin dépendra directement de ces
décisions sur le papier il existait déjà
un jardin conçu par la société
d'aménagement
ils étaient plus petits 4 hectares au
lieu de six c'était un petit parc à la
française avec fontaine et gedo signé
paradoxalement par un paysagiste anglais
mais ce jardin même agrandi à maintenant
peu de chances d'être réalisé
on sait en effet que le ministère des
affaires culturelles a reçu l'ordre de
contacts et de nouveaux paysagiste et
qu'il est en train de le faire quand on
interroge ces derniers sur la lure du
nouveau parc
ils hésitent à se prononcer il faut
d'abord savoir sur quoi on va planter
reste l'aspect financier l'autre trou à
combler en l'absence de toute solution
de remplacement lardoise serait lourde
entre 300 et 700 millions de francs
suivant les estimations
rien qu'en perte de recettes et en
indemnités à verser
d'où la conclusion qu'en tire certains
le mètre carré supplémentaire du gazon
reviendrait à 4 millions nouveaux fronts
de quoi réveiller la nostalgie des
admirateurs de baltard qui peuvent se
consoler pour quelques jours encore avec
ses reste dérisoire